es oportuna esta respuesta a la
casablanca o se puede considerar tardía
con la valentina buenas noches creo que
es oportuna y es importante resaltar que
eeuu es el país que más casos tiene en
este momento de la vida del mono que es
una enfermedad altamente contagiosa sin
embargo se ha reducido
a un grupo de personas muy específicos
que es el de hombres que tienen sexo con
hombres casi en el 90 95 por ciento sin
embargo al ser el país con más casos sí
es una declaratoria que quizás se traiga
un poco porque se veía venir que ayuda
el incremento de casos de manera muy
importante y ya había sido resaltada por
la oms con una enfermedad de interés
internacional bueno y ahora con esta
declaración de emergencia sanitaria qué
pasa con la disponibilidad de las
vacunas y los tratamientos cómo cambia
este este mecanismo bueno que los
dineros que se van a hacer les va a ser
más fácil de hacer en eeuu van a
permitir avanzar la disponibilidad de
vacunas y tratamientos
o una gran cantidad de vacunas que
recién se secaron y de la capacidad que
tienen ahorita es limitada sin embargo
están viendo la posibilidad de que en
vez de que sea una inyección
intradérmica sea una inyección tipo la
vacuna que nos pusieron a los de mi
generación en los 50s de la vacuna
contra la vida edad tradicional que ella
es la única enfermedad erradicada esa
era si ustedes recuerdan los raspado en
la piel y no se inocula va en una
pequeña gotita de la vacuna y eso decían
las normas que prendía la vacuna y todos
los de mi generación nos una como cosa
aquí en el brazo o en el muslo de las
muchachas que había aprendido la vacuna
y hay alguna otra medida que pueda tomar
estados unidos otros gobiernos ante el
aumento en los contagios yo creo que
sobre todo la prevención es lo más
importante las medidas preventivas y no
estigmatizar a la población que
homosexual lo que tiene
desde que tienen sexo con hombres sino
que es una vez que sale de ese grupo la
dispersión por ser de contagio por la
saliva y del contacto directo puede
pasar a cualquier otro grupo poblacional
entonces porque la la prevención es lo
más importante es resaltar cuáles son
los primeros síntomas de la enfermedad y
que los médicos puedan diferenciar
rápidamente la enfermedad y que no la
vayan a confundir con otras enfermedades
exantemáticas o de la piel o de
prevenibles por vacunación como varicela
como de sarampión tos que todas esas
medidas de control y de prevención y de
capacitación al personal médico son
importantes para prevenir que vaya a
explorar y expandirse la infección